this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Neil it's a real pleasure to be
here and I'll thank Neil for being such
a great host and it's good to see them
again and it's good to see them thriving
here and it's a pleasure to be here I've
it's it doesn't seem like spring here
it's 82 degrees today in Sacramento
that's a little too warm for us but it's
a pleasure to be here nonetheless Anna
it's and it's also this symposia thing
lete lang and and Terrence put it
together it's it's a nickname the old
fart symposium because it's supposed to
be a bunch of a bunch of us tree crop
physiologist who who are in the process
retiring in the in the somewhat either
already retired or in this in the
relatively near future retiring and I
did get my degree in in at Davis but it
was in the body department and my PhD
was in beach and dune plant ecology so I
I never did have a formal course in
homology or horticultural in my life but
now I'm the primary homology instructor
at Davis so life is full of fun and I
really enjoyed my career in tree fruit
physiology I look at I look at the pom
ology as basically applied environmental
physiology with trees and I'm today I'm
going to talk about work that we've done
with rootstock physiology work primarily
I spent a lot of my time doing crop
modeling tree crop modeling and a whole
bunch of other sort of things i'll talk
about that on
on Wednesday of this week at the Geneva
meeting so I thought I'd do something a
little different here today and about 30
years ago now Scott Johnson and myself
teamed up with a USDA scientists who had
been collecting potentially dwarfing
rootstocks for peach Scott Johnson
actually was a graduate from Cornell
he's one of Ellen lacks those early PhD
students and he's the extension
specialist at Kearney at the Kearney AG
center which is in the in the Central
Valley of California he and I have done
a lot of work together and we we started
looking at these root stocks and and are
typical for these are all going to talk
about peach exclusively today our
standard peach root stock in California
is nima guard it's a very vigorous
rootstock selected for root-knot
nematode resistance and vigor our
growers are interested in having a much
are having some size reduction and less
pruning costs and so on so we we began
looking at some of these selections from
that program we started out with 122
different accessions of genotypes we've
narrowed and we we got about 80 two of
those to route from hardwood cuttings
and from that we narrowed it down to two
ten that looked reasonably good and then
we finally ended up with these two
controller nine and contort are called
controller nine in control or five year
and this hiawatha is an old root stock
from South Dakota but they all had some
dwarfing so this is the the trunk
circumference a--'s and you can see
there's some dwarfing after 12 years and
this is the standard open base tree
these are perpendicular V or a v-shaped
tree they also been consistently with
two different tops two different science
so the trees aren't tremendously smaller
but this is an image
guard our load LP chand emma guard and
this is the one on the crow trailer 9
this is controller 5 the size of the
trees isn't that much smaller but the
openness of the trees is much greater
and we have much less response to
pruning when we prune these two as
opposed to this as you can see here this
is some of the from the early again two
different two different tops and two
different training systems and
consistently this is the dry mass of
dormant prunings well actually summer in
Dorne who needs to put together and you
can see the difference in the pruning
wait it's quite significant subsequent
to that early study Fred bliss came to
Davis and started looking at additional
crosses and Harold blood by Okinawa
Okinawa cross was was really really
through a lot of variation in size
controlling potential and so we released
for more root stocks in addition to the
initial to the initial to our controller
9 and controller 5 controller 5 its
trees actually almost too small and it
produces small fruit so we don't want we
don't want door fruit when they have a
dwarf tree but these others are all
producing reasonably I mean yeah
reasonably sized fruit compared to trees
on nimma guard and so we so we released
all of these six and these numbers
basically represent something relative
to the size of demo guard so this should
be about ninety-five percent so just
slightly reducing nineteen ninety-five
percent eighty percent seventy percent
of sixty percent more or less and fifty
percent of trees on number guard so
while we did all that sort of evaluation
sorts of work as a physiologist I got
more and more interested in
and adoring mechanism and so I'm going
to talk mainly about that and so way
back in nineteen thirty-nine looking at
Molly nine and some of the mall Ingrid
stocks beak painted and Thompson
beakbane they were both at East Molly
they analyzed the anatomy of the xylem
and phloem and so on in dwarfing at
Apple rootstocks and they showed that
the cross sectional area a design
cross-sectional area the various a fruit
stocks composed of fiber Frank and when
vessel raised and the percent of fibers
and vessels were proportional to the
vigor of the root stocks imparted to the
same and the more dwarfing rootstocks
had smaller vessels than vigorous root
stocks and but well then they concluded
that at least a partial explanation of
the mechanism of rootstock effect may be
obtained from a study of internal
structure of the fruit trees they were
very cautious about assigning any causal
relationship between xylem vessel
characteristics of the root stock versus
a sign to the dwarfing and the reason
for that is summarized in this review
which is an annual review of plant
physiology by Rogers and big bang and
and so that at that in that review they
said that they were basically three
potential mechanisms to explain sign
read stock interactions one was nutrient
may differ greatly in a capacity for
absorbing storing and utilizing
nutrients one was in transport focused
on the phloem transport but acknowledged
the differences in sizing and size the
numbers of vessels are sufficient to
success suggest that the capacity of the
island for water transport would be
higher and vigorous than a dwarf plants
but this may not be a limiting factor
based on the view that the number of
vessels in the stems is normally greatly
in excess of that
required to transport water so as you
know we have lots and lots of xylem area
and trees and so they basically said
well it doesn't make sense that this can
actually be a limiting factor because in
general we think that there's excess
silent capacity and then the one related
to to growth regulating substance
substances which basically has been sort
of the principal mechanism that's been
bandied around for the rest for the last
60 years so I had a graduate student but
in the 90s late 90s who basically
described some of these early rootstocks
that we're looking at and what the
growth characteristics were we had and
basically the new peach root stocks are
affected or limited shoot length growth
that is and that was basically the
internode lengths but not the number of
nodes and trunk girth was was decreased
in the number as we saw already in the
previous slide or the slides ago and the
number of and length of water sprouts
the epic cormac shoots tended to be less
with it with the size controlling root
stocks and there was a hint that the
trees on divorcing rootstocks had no
lower more more negative midday stem
water potentials so based on that work
that early descriptive work and on a
study that I a previous student of my
did we showed that chute extension
growth is is a linear function of the
temperature and late and the rate of a
change of stems water potential in
peaches now this is a little bit
counterintuitive because before you look
at that so
what time of day is a shoot growth the
greatest shoot extension growth what
type of day is shoot extension growth
the greatest in the fruit tree early in
the morning why water potential the
highest yep okay anybody else want to
guess why you got sugar accumulation
yeah alright so it turns out that
contrary to the water water hypothesis
afternoon is that is a period of most
rapid stem extension growth so this is
this is the extension growth rate here
and you see that its peak is about six
o'clock 1800 hours most people because
they're so fixated on water relations
immediately talk about think about the
mid the the dawn water potential being a
driver but in fact temperature
temperature is is one of the most
significant factors there ever driving
growth and the availability of
carbohydrates li liang is focused on
carbohydrates so that's involved there
but anyway we could we could basically
model this stem extension growth rate as
a function at linear function of the
recovery the recovery of water potential
from the mid day low the rate of
recovery of water potential from the mid
day low plus the temperature and so we
got a fairly good regression to that
well so under really realizing that or
understanding that i went back and we
thought okay let's take a look at these
root stocks in the field so we did this
experiment with nima guard hiawatha and
k 146 43 which is controller 5 now and
in this range is a range of size
reduction and sure enough that we did
this we did these diurnal patterns of
extension growth rate relative extension
growth rate and and stem mid and stem
water potential over the day and sure
enough the the most size controlling had
the most negative minimum water
potential and so forth and as the spring
warmed up that those differences
especially with the controller five or
the K 14 643 was much negative more
negative and and this was as the spring
kept going but then as as you end up in
June the differences became a little bit
less but were so when we put that all
together we we came up with this sort of
integrated daily stem fluctuation in
mega pascals per hour and the k1 4643
was was the most affected or that had
the lowest integrated water potential
fluctuation and then the Hiawatha in
between and emma guard here so I
convinced us that yes indeed the water
relations thing is something going on
with water relations and this is this is
the water sprout length or epic cormac
shoot length in those same trees that we
were looking at this other and this is
the accumulated integrated stem
fluctuation and we we again a very good
relationship the lengths of water
sprouts which grow sort of
indeterminately through the whole season
and this and this and Waterston and and
stem water potential so then I so we
were now fairly convinced that water
potential had something to do with it
then I had another student Luis solari
and we decided ok in order to nail us
down we
we should manipulate water potential so
what we did was or what he did I should
say you know professors faculty always
say we but it's really the student that
does all that work they were less I'll
continue to say we anyway what we did
what he did was he wrapped the shoot to
stop the rep transpiration and then put
this this sort of insulating this is
like a space blanket material over the
top and so that the shoots didn't heat
up and he either he either covered zero
thirty percent or sixty percent of the
canopy with he's with this material in
the evening before a warm summer day and
the idea here it was to see whether we
could Mittleman IPPY late water
potential and get again a range of water
potentials and still see this change in
in in stem extension growth rate so
basically by doing it on he did that on
the three rootstocks so nehme guard
hiawatha and k 146 or controller five
and you see immediately that this is the
stem water potential and always that the
more dwarfs remove stock had a lower
water potential but we could indeed
raise that water potential by covering
thirty or sixty percent of the canopy
and so that we had basically overlapping
water potentials between the nemah guard
and in the hiawatha and 146 43 and we
did that we this is the relative stem
extension growth rate and then we get a
corresponding overlap in stem extension
growth rates so there's a direct
correlation on the three rootstocks
three different routes toxin directly
related to water potential so
and this this shows the relationship
more clearly as a graph with all with
all the points on it differing amounts
of cover of coverage and so forth I'll
put together so there there there
appears to be a direct relationship of
that so then and then when that
experiment was done with a small trees
he we used a a hydraulic pressure
machine to measure to measure specific
hydraulic conductance of the plant of
the the shoot the root and are the shoot
part in the root part and then put them
together the whole tree so basically
what you do is you cut the tree off you
measure the hydraulic conductance of the
upper part and then you turn the thing
around and put it on the root and force
the water backwards through there
there's a little bit of concern about
forcing weather forcing water backward
through the root is the right thing to
do but nevertheless you still get you
still get these differences so assuming
that the differences would be relative
you see that when there's no difference
between the treatments with a science so
all of these had to send them the same
sign on top same peach sign on top after
got exactly what it was but they're all
the same but they're just on different
root stocks but the rootstock
consistently had nehme guard the root of
emma guard had a higher specific
hydraulic at least specific hydraulic
conductance and so the the difference
was in the rootstock not in the sign
and then a student that wasn't quite
enough for him so we did this additional
experiment where we put the plants in
these these chambers we grew the plants
in the chambers for a number of years he
had a whole slew of other ones that he
did some other experiments but the these
chambers you're able to were able to
seal them up and and apply pressure air
pressure to the bottom while there while
they're growing and we moved them to a
growth chamber and did this work and
this kind of work has been done before
with other plants it's sort of it's sort
of documents that yes water potential
actually works and and the system as we
think of it actually works you apply
pressure to the rootstock are to the
roots and you and it you can indeed as
you apply pressure the leaf water
potential of the of the scien changes
proportionally so you apply pressure and
the roots and the rootstock water I mean
the sign water potential increases it
maintain the difference between the the
two root stocks so in this case we just
add to the nemah guard vs the controller
5 or K 1 4643 and so that the more
negative 1 is the is controller 5 or the
dwarfing root stock and the other one is
the rigorous root stock so that so the
relative extension and it and this is
the corresponding relative extension
growth rate of these root stocks I mean
of the shoots so again we can manipulate
the water potential and we by doing so
we manipulate the shoot extension growth
rate so the sort of nails it in terms of
yes indeed the rate of growth or the
rate of stem extension growth on the
roof stock is directly related to water
water relations and and he also measured
then
the the the hydraulic conductance again
least specific hydraulic conductance of
these two and and again the Sian not
really well in this case slightly
different but not a whole lot different
but the but the roof stock is where most
of the difference was doing here and
here so then I had this this visiting
scientist from Italy came and and he
said you know you've done all this stuff
I read all your papers and it would be
interesting to look at the xylem Anatomy
I said well certainly it can't be that
easy this whole thing can't be that
simple but he went went ahead and he he
measured the xylem vessel
characteristics and then calculated
axial hydraulic conductance of the size
of the size controlling rootstocks and
in this case he did nimma guard and the
controller nine and controller five and
sure enough he got differences in in the
these are classes of root root size
categories and in the in and and this is
so this is now the shoots of each one of
these so these are these are actually
these were taking from our from our
foundation plant services block where we
have that's used for distribution of of
grafting wood or routing wood and so
these are actual shoots of the rootstock
here these are the trunks of the
rootstock and these are the roots of the
rootstock and so we saw these consistent
differences again in all these parts of
having a greater number of large size
vessels in the more
more vigorous rootstocks and a greater
proportion of smaller side vessel in the
in the more dwarfing rootstocks and if
you put all this together and calculate
we didn't weighted mean vessel diameters
you see that that consistently well
fairly consistently at least the nemah
guard regardless of whether you looked
at the shoots the trunks or the roots
had the largest mean weighted mean
vessel diameters and the next one had
the intermediate and the most size
controlling had had the next most or
next smallest vessels so it did seem to
be directly related to vessel diameter
and and they just seem it does seem to
be as simple as just the anatomy of the
of the rootstock and then when you
calculate the Quetta he used this these
data in vessel diameters weighted mean
vessel diameters and so on to calculate
the theoretical xylem conductance based
on the Pye saw law which is basically
the the conductance or the resistance
conductance through a vessel or a pipe
is is a function of the radius to the
fourth power and and and sure enough it
matter what you looked at demo guard had
the highest conduct a calculated
theoretical Huck conductance in the
others fell in line so we're fairly
fairly certain that that we had a story
here but then we also wanted to know
whether how much influenced because
there is the notion that the the
rootstock will influence the anatomy of
the science or vice versa and so we did
we had a tree where we
well no wait this is
yeah so this is the sign the sign on on
each of the root stocks versus the root
stock and so this is and and so you see
the Sian was basically identical across
when when when grafted on the three root
stocks but the rootstock maintained
their differences just like we saw
before and and this is the the
calculated hydraulic conductance of
those again showing that that indeed the
sign more or less they'd the same it was
all in the root stock and then we happen
to have some trees where we would put
where he had put controller nine as an
interest in and we had oh Henry which is
a vigorous sian and nimah guard was a
vigorous root stock and we looked at the
theoretical hydraulic we looked at the
the xylem vessel characteristics again
in this combination with a with a
vigorous root stock down in the bottom
an interest in here and a vigorous sign
on top and we looked at the theoretical
hydraulic calculated well we looked at
the P looked at the vessel sizes and all
that and calculated a weighted mean
vessel diameter and all that and then
calculated theoretical hydraulic
conductance and sure enough it came out
that basically the most morphing
rootstock when using inner stem had no
effect in either direction on the on the
vessel diameter a vessel anatomy of the
rootstock out of the others
um
then we had this series you notice
remember I talked about we had we had
four additional rootstocks that we
released so he looked at the anatomy the
vessel characteristics of those four and
again we saw that that the the primary
the truck the primary effect was on the
was was on the roofs and that it was in
line with with with the dwarfing
characteristics there was also in this
case he looked at the trunks as well let
me see here so then we had a I had a
just last year I had a geneticist
breeder a peach breeder who was
interested that peach rootstocks come
from Brazil and he said well if that's
the case which should be able to figure
out we if we're going to breed
rootstocks in the future it'd be really
interesting if we could use this as a
selection tool but it but it's going to
have to be simpler than then what Tom
basie did because today see you looked
at he did a lot of calculations the very
laborious and so on so what this so what
cloudian bruckner did was he looked for
some very simple characteristics that
you could look at doing cross-section of
shoots of these of these different root
stocks and he came up with with the
number of vessels around the largest
vessel over the number of vessels of
nimma garden so so basically he
developed a simple selection criteria by
which he felt as a plant breeder he
would he would and then he tested
whether he would be able to sort him out
or not depending on if he had a ten
percent or fifteen percent there a
20-percent sort of variance and in
selection criteria and he decided that
yes he could certainly he could
certainly sort out the more size
controlling rootstocks
having a quick simple simple assay like
this so so he's hopeful that he can
actually use this sort of information in
this in his rootstock breeding program
so now we're going back to the beat bein
question and how can I island vessel
diameter and theoretical hydraulic
conductance of the outer rings of the
xylem which is what we measured be
limiting when there appears to be an
excess of xylem capacity in other words
why weren't Rogers in beak bein correct
so I've been troubled by this for
actually quite a few years and we didn't
Tom basically came back we did this
short experiment a couple years ago and
the experiment the experiment was
basically we did girdling so in
California for our peach production
especially early maturing peach
productions it's actually quite common
that we will the grower will girdle the
trees which basically means you take a
quarter inch ring of bark out in the
spring six weeks before harvest six
weeks before your anticipated harvest
you take that the ring of bark off they
are down to the cambium and then and
then that artificially holds the
carbohydrates in the upper part of the
tree makes the fruit larger and it makes
it about three three or four or five
days earlier and the tree doesn't die I
mean contrary to all the stuff about
girdling the tree doesn't die the if you
only do that a quarter inch the it grows
callous across the girdle and by the
time of harvest the girdles mended again
the tree looks a little sick but but it
recovers and you can do this year after
year after year so we did that then we
did 22 times of journaling an early
girdle and a late girl and our
hypothesis was that well and most
girdling people assume that it's only
the transport
of sugars that's affected not the
transport of water okay but we were we
reasoned well we're not so sure that so
this has been a conundrum in the girdle
in literature for years why shoot growth
is actually usually shorter on girdle
trees while fruit growth is larger
because the fruit growth is larger
because more carbohydrates held up in a
tree but why wouldn't that excess
carbohydrate and the tree stimulate
shoot growth so this is a problem that's
been banging around a literature for a
while so we did this experiment and we
looked at the midday stem water
potentials after dirtily so here's the
early girdle the midday stem water
potential of the early girdle dropped
significantly compared to the control
the controls that the triangles here and
then the late girdle it it dropped also
relative to control but but both of them
both of them sort of caught up again so
what's the interpretation here our
interpretation is that that the girdling
not only affected phloem flow it
affected xylem flow because when you
girdle you're also hitting the cambium
so you're hitting the cambium that's
going to stop the development of new of
new phloem I mean new xylem for that
period so new xylem growth stops and so
until it until it rebounds you see this
effect and and there's also recently in
the last two or three four years there's
mounting evidence that water transport
trees in ring toward xylem with ring for
asylum relies primarily on the most
recently formed ring of xylem maybe two
rings of xylem and in fact
oh this is the this is a number of water
sprouts retreat it also affected the
number of water sprouts per tree and so
on but there are there is something
published in the literature way back in
1890 that said that robinia if you
girdle to rovenia some at particular
time of the year the tree would die if
you did this light girdle whereas if you
did it in the spring but if you did it
in the in the fall there was no effect
so this is sort of consistent with that
and and and and people that are doing
the hydraulic conductance met with with
the probes they're also finding that if
you put the probe do deep you don't you
can't measure the hydraulic conductance
nearly as well as if you if you keep it
in the outer layers of xylem so there's
an increasing recognition that it is the
hour earlier as I am that's important so
this goes back to the rootstock thing
because if transport of the water
transport in a plant is primarily
dependent on the last year or the
current new growing silam as well as may
be the last year's island that's going
to have an influence on having smaller
vessels in the rootstock will have
influence on the water potential of
those plants and so I think we have a
story so basically
recent rain that is that well obviously
there's some movement in the previous
year's Island but the the efficiency of
the current year Asylum is thought to be
much as it's developing us to be thought
to be much higher than the previous
year's Island and I think this varies by
species probably but anyway so a summary
of the way we think about this now is
that of how the root stocks at peach
rootstocks work is that the diet the
diameter of the water conducting vessels
of the divorce rootstock are smaller
this call is a hydraulic conductance of
the rootstock and the water cannon
tissue to be lower this causes the water
availability or water potential in the
stems and leaves to be slightly less
this causes the elongation of stems to
be slightly less and overall bigger the
tree is decreased over time and this is
particularly true of the water sprout
parts of the after cornick shoots this
decreases the amount of pruning needed
the decreased pruning reduces the number
of water sprouts that are produced in
the following year because if water
sprouts are produced in response to
pruning pretty much only and this
decreases the need for pruning even more
so you have a cumulative fecht of less
pruning and this decreases the internal
canopy shading and thus increases shoot
quality and flower bud development we I
don't show you data on that but
typically the bloom on on the size
controlling rootstocks is much heavier
than the bloom on the daughter on the
vigorous root stocks
so question is can we simulate this so
I've done a lot of work with what we
call the LPG model it's a linen L stands
for lindenmayer it's a particular
modeling language and i'll just show you
a movie of the simulation of the growth
of two peach trees one-on-one anna on a
vigorous rootstock and one in which the
hydraulic conductance of the rootstock
only is reduced by fifty percent and so
we can get this to run I might have to
go out yeah yeah apple just get this one
okay let me there is okay so what we
have here are three identical trees the
first two years have already been
simulated so the initial year in the
nursery and the first year then in the
nursery after that they grown in a
nursery for a year they grow a girl main
stem that's that's in the way we grow
two trees in California that main stem
is then hacked off and be high about and
then you then you allow shoots to grow
out of that and then in the sub in the
summer I mean the winter of the
subsequent year so that after the trees
are really two years old one year in
orchard we have we have three types of
pruning here so it's exactly the same
tree simulated in each case but there's
three different types of pruning this is
what we call the dinuba pruning which is
a group of growers very conservative
growers in the southern San Joaquin
they'd like to have all their trees to
really just grow like heck in the in the
second year in the orchard and so they
prune them back to about a foot stubs or
8-inch stubs three scaffolds and a
perpendicular an open base tree this
one's the same tree except it's sort of
our standard recommendation that is that
you leave these these scaffolds each to
be about a meter long and this is yeah
anyway and then we have what Scott
Johnston and Kevin day and myself are
sort of trying to promote is leaving the
tree less hard pruned selecting some of
the fruiting wood off of here and so on
and then letting them go so we have a
simulation now a movie of this the
subsequent one year's worth of growth in
this case with for with music for your
pleasure
well I should say what we're doing I
forgot to explain what the model does
what the model does is basically it
grows the tree and while I was growing
that the growth of the tree is totally
dependent on the carbon that's
assimilated by the leaves of the tree it
basically simulates the photosynthetic
output of every single leaf and and then
distribute then that that carbohydrate
is to distribute it around the tree
according to the sink strength of all
the individual organs that are on there
and then we have a whole bunch of sub
model than they're dictating what the
what individual shoots look like
depending on if they're epic or Makar
proleptic or what have you and so you'll
see the differences between the three
these two are going to grow a little bit
of fruit as well
so we have spring it's blooming
you look carefully you see some green
fruit in here that turn yellow
we just had thinning there those in the
front you may have seen the fruit some
fruit disappear it's simulating every
hour of every day and now you're going
to see harvester you're pretty quick
there's harvest
so if you I don't have stopped it but
the tree on the left that was really
hard pruned ended up to be of almost the
same size as a tree in the center and
that's and that's because yeah stop the
air you go so this tree ended up to be
almost the same size of this one and
that's because by hard pruning like this
we grew almost exclusively epicor
Macoutes which have no stop point epic
wiremock shoots growth differently than
and this one has some epic aren't these
really tall ones are the water sprouts
that came out of these high heads but
there's many other shoots in here that
are proleptic shoots and this one of
course had many many more proleptic
shoots and still had a few epic or me
shoots where we did a heading cut so it
sort of it sort of explains how you can
actually these growers that do this are
set on this because they get these very
uniform trees they have lots of choices
for secondary scaffolds and everything
whereas you do these and you have a
little more random structure because
you're not forcing as much growth but it
explains why these guys can be satisfied
with this as compared to the traditional
system because by the end of the season
there's not that much difference and
that's really the way what happens in
the field as well but you might you you
would have noticed that there were more
more fruit obviously on these and so
many of our growers are going to less
and less pruning because we're
understanding this more and more so I
want to go back to the thing here I can
get out of this
I'm back to this but I'm not to go all
the way back oh no here we are so yeah
right there so I want to acknowledge our
collaborators on this project it's been
basically 25 years of work off and on so
in terms of the development of the
rootstock initial the initial to Dave
ramming was the USDA researcher material
came from him Scott Johnson Kevin day
and Jim Doyle we did all of the field
analysis and then control controller six
seven eight and nine point five Fred
bliss was a faculty member battalion
Eddie was a technician of his that did
almost most of the work and these guys
also have been helping this is a
graduate student and then all of the
physiology initially done by Weibo and
we had Boris Vasily from Italy Jordi
Marcel from Spain Louis Solari from the
student from Uruguay and 22 from Italy
and one from Brazil and then the
modeling stuff which I really just
showed you a little bit about and that's
been sort of the main occupation of my
mental whatever mental stuff I have left
we David de Silva in the last four years
has been really instrumental in that as
well as Romeo Romeo Favreau is it really
interesting guys about 86 now and he was
working in our lab until a year and a
half ago on a voluntary basis for about
6 years 8 years he was a computer
scientist that was at the input at the
very beginning of introduction of
computers into the world into into
commerce he installed the the first main
strain computer main frame computer in
in Europe back in the 50s 60s and then
these two guys also worked on a model
quite a bit so I think that's it
like three year tension
yeah I have two questions the first part
is weighted exactly Colonel those trees
you mentioned that in a month amia two
weeks a month before harvest oh but you
know no not no next day so we did April
how you did it the first one is April
early April the second one I think was a
april or she may I think early I think
late April it'll set it on the thing but
getting at boylston markula I just want
to make sure so you measure the midday
stand keep in mind that our our our our
bloom an art to love our swing is yes
now March 10-4 for the speech yep right
yeah with all that in mind but do you
think the news item and development
provides a significant if akin amount of
water to those plants last two weeks
after the garlic that's my question
apparently okay now we know that the
time of the initial movement of sugars
of the tree is all in desirable the
plums non-functional so the initial
movement of sugar up the tree of the
spring is it as I'll so there's got to
be some functionals I no question about
that but apparently that that news
island is being developed is more
efficient or is sr only interpretation
and the interesting thing is we look at
we look at that water relations thing
that we see the difference in water
relations it holds up until about the
end up into June if you measure the
difference in water relations between
trees on the worgen stocks and
rootstock in July and August there
there's no significant difference in the
stand waters potential usually very
difficult to detect one and my
interpretation now is that is that the
new ring of xylem is being formed and
that's an accident because it's that the
vessels in that ring are smaller that
that is actually hindering the pilot
hydraulic conductance of that new shoe
growth and the end then grow up in that
tree for that for that early part of the
season one that when you get adequate
new rings of
thailand then you have the nut vessels
even though they're smaller to match the
capacity of the requirement of the top
that's that's our interpretation at the
front of time and do you is that men
verify economically we haven't we
haven't done that we haven't done that
we should do that additional thing
looking at the actually the width of the
design and calculate the total hydraulic
capacity of the phone ring we did so far
was just look at the new bring all of
all that silence tough want related to
the new ring but only one section I mean
only a microscopic view my second
question is since the dorsum mechanism
in peach is primarily limitation on
water transport do you think with the
same root stocks will we see last north
in fact in New York versus California
how Bob takes effect on for size because
water is so important for fruit size
well that's I think why we get the
problem with with controller five it has
the small
controller 5 was in the early earlier NC
140 full trial the National rootstock
trial the people into the ark where they
liked it because for debris and it has
higher cold tolerance that may be
related to this vessel size 2i only it's
what's safer but but the rootstock but
but the fruit in California is too small
to be an acceptable restock for
commercial production fell apart now
controller 6 is the next step up and
it's a parable of I Okinawa one would
think that it would have a fruit size
problem but for some reason and i'm not
sure we don't understand why harvest is
delayed a week with controller six so we
think that while it may have an
inherently smaller fruit size if it's
harvest at the same time because you had
a week to it is able to make up a bit of
the difference and so it has acceptable
fruit size but we're quite excited
perfect actual is the other two are then
getting close enough to navegar that is
very difficult to see a difference in
fruit size
yeah the absence of native apple that if
you grabbed an inner stand to do a
three-part tree and its working interest
in reforming the proportional to the
length of the same in here same with
this I think the same so some apples and
Molly nine it's a more complicated story
but lack so one of the other people have
reported it also relaxo wood and this
student here early student anyway they
reported that Holly nine hadn't had a
lower water potential trees on science
i'm balling nine how to lower more
potential than trees some seasoning or
more big jar but i wasn't that was
published years ago already but they
sort of left it there I think sort of in
the same conundrum that big page was in
and we were all in that but the male 9
is also different in that that you have
this lower growth there's signs of some
sort of foaming compatibility or
something going on
there as well so I think that I think
that is a more complicated rootstock
situation but what I think water is
involved but it's certainly not the
whole story you here now and again that
California might be having it throughout
issue and so I was just curious given
that you're conducting microbes that you
may be having a special challenges in
your research or something that you had
emailed you back to the clinic make
amends for I'm just kind of curious
about that well yeah we all have to make
special things this particular year
because water is not everyone's mind and
sledding what's happening now is that
so California has a very complicated
water distribution system all of the
tradition of many of the traditional
water districts on the east side of
Silicon Valley in the center of the
valley they all have these Drabek Drabek
fed your hand districts and many of
those will be probably eating something
like forty to sixty percent of the
normal location the ones the ones that
are on that and those are all local
irrigation district more or less local
irrigation districts but ones that are
on the federal irrigation or state
irrigation projects like the California
Aqueduct basically the water on the west
side of the San Joaquin Valley and the
one and that water continues to flow
into Kelly all that's all of us
California water project and what
happens with that water is is basically
water that's pumped out of out of the
Delta before the Delta runs into the San
Francisco Bay so the water is fresh
enough it's pumped out of that not the
hill and then and then reverse rap down
the valley and then pumped a couple more
times every time it gets to load pumped
up hiring it low but that water that
water is is
they're out loud most of the growers on
that side are going to be zero of their
allocation some of them twenty percent
so those people are the ones that are
going to be really early and and much of
that land this year growers some growers
of permanent free travel also have have
annual crops tomatoes melons whatever
usually most of the crew they'd say if
they're growing two types of crop on
different pieces of land most of Oakland
will not plant their annual their annual
crop and they'll use whatever what are
they can find to keep their perennial
crop alive and then they'll do that
largely about companying the ground
water but the problem in that area is
the ground water depending on where you
are it can be very sailing or quite
similar so right now at the moment
everybody is flipping coins and drawing
straws as to as to whether the lack of
water is going to be the worst thing or
whether this will save the salinity of
the water but but I'm sure it's all
going to be worse no doubt about that
and then north in the sandwich in the
Sacramento Valley there's also similar
sort of water distribution becomes
River up the rice growers there's a lot
of rice in California believe it or not
in this drought state we have we draw a
lot of rice the north is in the
Sacramento Valley there would be a lot
some of that won't be planted or people
may plant those people are probably
forty to fifty percent of their
allocation and so a lot of that they
will plant half their land and use the
water from the whole allocation to do
the half of the land something like that
because the price of rice at the moment
is really good so there's previously we
have kind of her house a lot of the
price of rice was really level so those
guys up there sold their water to the
people down south water main systems in
step in the water market in California
but this year that probably won't happen
much because agriculture in California
barring the drought is is the most
lucrative I've ever seen it in my and my
30
this 35 years of being at university and
they're all many crops are in high
demand with high prices and almonds
walnuts and pistachios are a really
remarkable simulation yes Alan
oh yeah geez you want to do point out
you get similar results that you
mentioned with good apple of what we
found was that at the top of the
rootstock the working stuck at a lower
water potential more stressed but then
as you went out the branches there was a
decrease in water potential due to the
friction but that was the slope of that
was the same regardless in the Sian but
what happened is when you get out to the
end of the branch you had the same water
potentials but on the working stock you
got to the water potential with a one
meter long range and with the more
vigorous one you started with a higher
water potential so it took two meters of
growth to get to that same water
potential word stopped so the outside of
the trees all ended up with the same
water potential but it's very with the
rootstock that they can do center of the
tree really we never we haven't looked
at that down to shoot at all was that
with you and bill yep filling totally
okay I remembered that part of this of
it yeah study other what did you publish
that part of the study that was 30 years
ago I think so I'll look for you but
that's okay you please just skim the
paper
if you have any other questions spots
how they go all right I'll see you the
knife
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu